c'est absolument incroyable parce que à
chaque fois que je vous fais une vidéo
sur un smartphone de chez tommy cela
commence par xiaomi encore frappé et là
c'est encore le cas schumi a encore
frappé je peux vous en parler maintenant
ça fait quelques jours que tu es avec
moi c'est le xiaomi 11 tu es pro et je
vous le dis la première chose que je
vois c'est que la boîte elle est lourde
je les ai vus parce que j'étais sur la
conférence sur le tournage de la
conférence d'ailleurs pas si vous avez
vu c'est très très drôle j'ai beaucoup
père est allé voir la conf en ligne de
shiomi
[Musique]
et
c'est trompeur je connais ont tué
m
ils ont eu un rippeur dernière
il faut dire que j'ai fait une connerie
en
france vous font des petits films c'est
scénarisé on vous expliquant les specs
et on rentre qui perd sympa c'est super
important de pouvoir a participé à ce
tournage allez voir sur leur chaîne
youtube aller partout que c'est vraiment
vraiment top alors aujourd'hui je vous
parle de ce smartphone c'est le chien
hui le 11 tu es pro et le 11 tes propos
il est dingue dingue ou alors en
préambule ça fait un petit moment que
j'ai pas tourné ici donc là j'en profite
on est dimanche avant la sortie le
smartphone il est là je vous ferai le
test dans quelques jours donc laissez
moi le temps mais avant toute chose on
va se regarder et vous allez voir c'est
super intéressant parce que c'est le
premier smartphone qui sont sur le
marché avec une charge rapide 120 watts
oui je vous parle bien d'une charge
rapide 120 watts pas du 25 watts pas
d'une 65 watts d'une 120 watts alors ils
ont fait plein de trucs pour ça
fonctionne n'a pas de vue de
technologique et aussi des choses qui a
priori son point de vue logiciel à
l'intérieur pour venir justement
surveiller tout ça parce que du 120
watts en revanche quand même un peu du
bois mais juste avant de commencer eh
bien ça smartphones qui va falloir bien
protégé oui comment avec une coque de
kid nos partenaires et nos fils et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que oui
vous le savez vous plaît venez voir par
là sherine au chignon coque il y en a
pour tout le monde il ya tous les prix
et chérimont chine il va y avoir de plus
en plus de produits pour xiaomi il y en
a dans l'univers d'harry potter alors
moi je suis un très grand fan d'harry
potter et j'adore l'univers harry potter
vous avez une petite coque sur d'auby ça
ça me plaît énormément vous avez
également des coques sur fortnight learn
and coke est super jolie dans l'univers
fortnight alors je vous le dis une fois
de plus un des coques sur vos
smartphones de chiots mais on va en
avoir rien nada jamais regardé avoir de
plus en plus et y en aura regardé là
c'est super sympa one piece vous allez
en avoir sur le chu young 11 t sur le
chien au 1011 tpr ont regardé ça là
aussi sur harry potter est ce qu'elle
n'est pas super canon je trouve ça hyper
hyper canaux one piece aussi hyper
classe fortnight j'adore ricky est mort
tu y ailles mist ils ont pu faire mrg re
ça fonctionnerait aussi luca toni ok my
hero academia league of legends fraises
aussi on a encore du ori potter et
vouvry surtout vous avez différentes
couleurs donc un argument pour tous les
goûts et encore un ricky est morte si
vous en avez dans tous les univers dans
plein d'univers y en a énormément leur
linge vous montre des coques parce que
des coques comme ça vous allez en avoir
bien évidemment pas votre chiot miron se
tait et votre onze tu es pro mais il ya
aussi des bonnes peur des mots nick ya
plein de trucs vous pouvez venir
également personnaliser les boutons si
vous avez par exemple d'apple watch et
bien vous pouvez venir la protéger très
très facilement donc là c'est aussi très
très bien si vous avez un iphone vous
pouvez venir protéger les caméras de
votre iphone pour qu'elle ne se raye pas
avec différentes teintes vous avez
également des protections d'écran mais
également des câble tressé deux mètres
et la gêne trois mètres et une fois de
plus vous allez avoir des coques pour
votre chiot mine ce texte est pro vous
allez à bord également des protections
d'écran elle arrive très prochainement
vous ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description et en plus de ça avec le
code greu 21 vous avez 5 % de remise sur
votre commande c'est une très bonne
nouvelle merci qui merci rhino chine
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
danse et ça regardez ça ça c'est la
boîte du xiaomi on se tait pro on va se
le boxer on va regarder une fois de plus
le test arrivera dans quelques jours
donc abonnez vous actionner la cloche
comme ça vous saurez tout va parler de
plein de choses on va se tester sur le
terrain en déplacement photos vidéos on
va regarder la charge regarder les
sécurité au niveau de la charge on a
tous voir regarder tout de suite qu'est
ce qu'on voit on voit qu'on vous écris
ici qu'on ait une caméra avec un capteur
principal de 100 8 mégapixels ok why not
j'ai de la recharge 120 watts avec une
grande batterie de 5 millions terreur ça
va aller très très vite on recherche de
0 à 100 % 17 minutes 0 100 % en 17
minutes on allait déjà très vite avec
des charges d'autres constructeurs en
une demi heure vous le recharger pareil
sur nul à 65 watts lassé de la 120 watts
on va quasiment doubler la vitesse de
charges c'est absolument démentielle on
va regarder d'ailleurs si ça fonctionne
bien on va regarder si c'est
relativement constant et on va regarder
ce qui se passe en termes de sécurité
logicielle à l'intérieur parce que ça va
vite quand même essayer de comprendre
comment est ce que je suis au mit à
travailler pour réussir à voir de la
recharge rapide 120 watts qu'on peut
aujourd'hui industrialisés commercialisé
donc ça c'est super intéressant on voit
qu'on a un écran amoled avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz son bac on
a des haut parleurs stéréo avec harman
kardon c'est très très bien et on voit
qu'on a le processeur le plus rapide
actuellement c'est le qualcomm
snapdragon 888 c'est un processeur 5g on
a le modem c'est le x 62 qualcomm comme
ça on se dit tout et on s'est tous alors
regardez à olonne j'aime beaucoup j'aime
toujours le design alors c'est très très
brillant attention aux traces de doigts
ici la trace de doigt plus plus plus
d'où l'intérêt de venir mettre une coque
de protection pas mal hein pas folle la
guêpe par contre j'adore ce petit côté
que j comme ça c'est très joli le module
photo qui est assez grand et sympa on
reste vraiment dans l'esthétique qu'on a
avec cette gamme me 11,2 xiaomi vous
savez qu'il ya un changement de nom
chéchia oui tout ce qui était sorti en
début d'année on appelle ça xiaomi me
donc mis 11 ils ont enlevé la
dénomination me je pense pour l'inter
sur l'internationalisation donc on a
passé aujourd'hui le chiot millions
c'était le 11 tu es pro ici à pas et
demi donc si avait pas eu de changement
s'attellerait shiomi l'union ceux des
pros mais comme il ya eu le changement
c'est le chien au mieux on se tait pro
là j'ai un petit micro qui est situé
juste là je pense pour tout
l'enregistrement vers un gros focus ce
qu'ils ont fait au niveau de la photo et
de la vidéo ça m'intéresse il est plat
sur le dessus c'est bien écrit ici
harman kardon alors je passe si vous
allez bien vous en rendre compte mais
voilà c'est bien écrit c'est que c'est
fait avec harman kardon on avoir un
petit micro pour la réduction de bruit
on a ici de l'infrarouge c'est une des
dernières marques qui vous propose de
l'infrarouge sur les smartphones pour
venir l'utiliser comme une télécommande
bon je pense que vous le faites ailleurs
dit clairement moi je le fais pas mais
en tout cas on peut le faire le bouton
de volume on va l'allumer on vient les
timbres en dessous on a la charge de
tiroirs de cartes sim le haut parleur on
a également ici bien petit micro pour
nous lire capter les appels
téléphoniques côté là on n'a absolument
rien très sympa regardons parce que ça
m'intéresse le bloc de charge de 120
watts
regardez ça je vais lui enlever parce
que j'ai toujours peur de ce choc ces
trucs regardez moi ça c'est ça qui fait
le poids en fait je me demande s'il pack
plus lourd que le smartphone en usb à
ici c'est pas du sbc par contre de
l'autre côté ici c'est bel et bien
l'usbc alors ensuite à l'intérieur eh
bien j'ai mon câble pour venir recharger
en usb en usd c'est ok sur les côtés
rien ici rien du tout non plus là j'ai
bien l'impression qu'ils les pas du tout
chargé at on bien va illustrer sa le
cordon on prend on branche je pense que
ça va être impressionnant je viens à
peine de le brancher j'étais à 2% je
suis à 8% et ça va extrêmement vite je
suis à 9 % 10 % est là pour autant tout
de suite j'ai pas du tout un smartphone
chaud au dollar voyez que je me dis du
120 watts derrière ça envoie forcément
du bois ça va venir chauffer alors là je
ressens pas peut-être un peu là là n'ont
pas encore pas encore vraiment pas mais
ça je vous ferai ce retour une façon
lors du test très très prochainement je
vais dans les paramètres batterie et
performance une marque 27 minutes
jusqu'à être complètement chargé 12% ses
frangins parce que mambé annonce de 0 à
17 minutes bon là c'est ce qui est écrit
donc je peux pas dire grand-chose
d'autre réparer un problème
d'utilisation de la batterie quel est le
problème fermer les applications qui
déchargent la batterie quelle est cette
application qui déchargent la batterie
je ne sais pas ajoutez-y minutes donc si
je clique là dessus ça me choque donc en
fait j'ai toute une application qui me
permet effectivement est bien de savoir
comment optimiser je peux ajouter 44
minutes en activant les économiseurs
d'énergie ok c'est pas le but a ajouté
10 mi temps dans sa le mode sombre ah
bah oui le mode sont en fait si vous
voulez ça va être intéressant parce que
comme ici j'ai un écran amoled bon c'est
une diagonale de 6,67 pouce si je passe
sur le thème sombre et bien j'adore un
d'écran moi qu'est ce qui se passe au
niveau d'une dalle amoled il ya quand
c'est noir à pixel est un donc
j'économise de l'énergie vous je ne vais
pas émettre de lumière c'est vachement
intéressant parce que je veux vraiment
tout ce qui se passe en temps réel et ce
qui vient consommer ok bon là c'est
qu'une installation donc j'ai pas tout
température de la batterie ok chargé
aujourd'hui base 0 x forcément aux
jeunes de l'allumer après l'expérience
que vous avez ici c'est me wade c'est un
global de boghé me wade 12 points 5
points 10 me voyais ça marche bien c'est
une très très belle expérience logiciels
en ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
smartphone et bien c'est tout l'aspect
toute la fiche technique parce qu'il est
complètement optimisé pour le gaming
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
est ce qu'on vient attendre aujourd'hui
d'un smartphone comme celui à qui coûte
quand même 1 649 faut enfin bref il est
dispo à partir de 649 euros ça c'est le
modèle pro vous avez également le xiaomi
11 t qui lui coûte 499 euros et vous
avez également 11 light 5 g n ait encore
une référence de plus sur cette gamme là
c'est pas un onze tu es là et c'est un
onze live donc ça veut dire qu'on reste
dans la gamme xiaomi 11 qu'on a connu en
début d'année mais c'est une nouvelle
référence c'est l'aèdes eux est celui là
que vous avez ici il est disponible en 8
128 go de stockage 8 256 go de stockage
mais également 12 256 go de stockage
donc on a de quoi faire et en plus ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vous avez
une fréquence d'échantillonnage tactile
de 480 m enfin vous allez jusqu'à 480 m
cela va apporter plus de réactivité
lorsque vous venez jouer à des jeux la
technologie drame c'est la lpddr2 5 donc
on a une fois de plus qui va mieux là
dessus pour le stockage c'est de lui fès
3.1 donc pareil en lecture et en
écriture ça ira très vite toute la
partie gaming lusage productivité on a
ce qu'il faut on a de la perf maintenant
il ya un autre truc qu'ils ont pas mis
de côté c'est toute la partie photo
vidéo c'est un des très gros usagers un
premier capteur principal c'est le 108
mégapixels ou très gros capteur qui
devrait laisser passer beaucoup de
lumière j'ai pas la taille du pixel à 6
et 2,1 micron j'ai la technologie 9
pixels en un qui va venir en fait
prendre 9 pixels vous les combinant d'un
gros pixels pour capter plus de lumière
donc ça peut être intéressant pour la
photo de nuit donc c'est tout l'intérêt
d'avoir beaucoup de pixels qui là encore
qui est d'une taille de pita qui soit
assez gros pour capter de la lumière
basse et de la physique il faut que la
lumière jaillit un ultra grand tante de
8 mégapixels avec un champ de vision de
120° ok why not j'ai une caméra de
maquereau de 5 mégapixels bon on
regardera ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit
à bagdad mais on regardera ça j'ai un
corning gorilla glass victuailles en
termes de résistance eu quand même pas
mal à l'avant fait de voir ce que ça
raconte au niveau des hauts parleurs
c'est pas mal de dieu un truc qui est
assez équilibré par contre je n'arrive
pas à savoir si le son sort de là ou si
le son sort de là peut-être des deux en
même temps l'expérience de
spatialisation comme ça sur une première
découverte tout ça vraiment pas mal en
plus ce qui est sympa que vous êtes du
bluetooth 5.2 donc on peut venir ça
paierait un casque très très facilement
j'ai pas du tout deux prises jack mais
rien de bien surprenant du wifi 6 donc
ça fonctionne rage également du nfc pour
tout ce qui va être paiement
dématérialisé c'est un smartphone qui
sont vraiment vraiment intéressant la
voyez je suis à 35 % de charge j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il va aussi vite que ce
qui n'est défini mais une fois de plus
un bel le tester prendre le temps de
regarder et je vous ferai un retour
complet et si j'en mets dans mes
paramètres voyez ils me disent qu'ils
aient il reste 20 encore 27 minutes
c'est très étrange disais tout à l'heure
il me le redis encore ok on va regretter
ça quand je suis en mode photo je vais
l'âge et le mode super macro là et la
gema macro voyez il ya un truc que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et café à pelé qu'on ne
retrouve pas ici est bien c'est que le
mode macro je dois venir l'actionner moi
même alors qu'apple sait ce que sont
très très très malin et bien ça se fait
intelligemment votre smartphone c'est et
il s'ouvre automatiquement macro et
c'est là où l'expérience est
intéressante et j'ai envie devrait venir
aussi améliorer ce point là ça arrivera
probablement celle du logiciel mais ça
serait vraiment intéressant là ça
commence à chauffer là je le fais à
l'envoyer sur le haut-lac ça chauffe
jolie smartphones on s'en reparle très
rapidement bien évidemment s'il vous
intéresse lien en bas dans la
description on regardera la partie photo
je vous dirai si ça chauffe lorsqu'on
joue je donnerai tout non retour sur
tout ce qui va être charge qui est un
des gros focus on va regarder la vidéo
c'est l'intérieur je pense qu'on peut
venir faire de la vidéo jusqu'à huit cas
ici donc on verra si c'est intéressant
on verra toutes ces parties là tous les
usages aura drastique effectivement le
gaming ça marche je suis convaincu que
le gaming marchera avec ce que vous avez
au niveau de la fiche technique pas là
c'est un beau smartphone il est
alléchant il est intéressant on
regardera si les promesses faites sont
tenus mais ça sera dans la vidéo test
d'ici là apportez vous bien fait des
gros et zoom prenez soin de vous et à
bientôt
[Musique]